comment fonctionne la production de
neige artificielle
c'est une question de tom et la neige de
culture comme préfère l'appeler les
professionnels de la montagne est
produite par des canons à neige ils sont
alimentés en eau et en mer comprimé par
des réseaux souterrains et fonctionne un
peu comme des brumisateurs géants grâce
à l'air comprimé l'eau est projetée hors
des canaux sous forme de fines
gouttelettes qui vont se cristalliser au
contact de l'air froid et se transformer
en neige avant de retomber au sol
cependant en y regardant de plus près il
est possible de distinguer cette neige
de culture de la neige naturelle à cause
de cette technique de production elle ne
se présente pas sous la forme de flocons
mais de petites billes de minuscules
granules sphérique autrement dit des
gouttelettes d'eau qui ont cristallisé